[Musique]
bonsoir des enfants
notre nounours est très mystérieux ce
soir au 1o au top
qu'est ce qui est si drôle nounours la
farce que j'ai préparé pas trop ce soir
vous allez tous être attrapé mon échelle
et hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
hop hop je suis sûr qu'il est en retard
of non non ça va quant à oullins
qui sait c'est une belle à nous montrer
qu'est ce que vous venez magasin vous
trouve à voir mais pana les enfants non
madame
elle est occupée vous voulez peut-être
on va acheter quelques boîtes maman ne
veux pas qu'on laisse entrer les gens
qu'on ne connaît pas il joue tellement
je me bats je voulais montrer aux tenues
regard du génie voulait pas beaucoup mon
petit à petit j'ai dit non si la lra
vous pouvez la garder
peugeot type de massage mais chacun fait
moi fois votre roman
magna
que joliment vous êtes une amphore
peureuse et vous bodyguard sont faites
moi voir votre monnaie je ne fais rien
voir du tout eh bien je m'en vais vous
pourquoi mon petit o o o au vu du buzz
ben salah mois aux hôtes du vin
tiana grand merci donc aux se suffisent
plus ce que je suis content drôle mollo
soit comme je suis content pour une fois
je voudrais bien notre album
[Musique]
d'accord je vous laisse toutes les
affaires de bolden sur la tempe
tout vole mon coach et et les boucles
d'oreilles le
pour denis le zoo en bonne nuit
farceur d'un amour ce bonne nuit madame
la bohémienne alors nounours tu t'es
bien amusé au trot crumble force
il ne m'avait pas reconnu le cher petit
au feu allons en route
mon bon ne nous route mobo pas trop
allez vite vous coucher les enfants
n'oubliez pas de faire votre toilette
plus faible boureux
[Musique]
e
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et